[Musica]
Ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata oggi sono in
compagnia di uno dei miei comici
preferiti Francesco De Carlo Benvenuto
Allora vogliamo iniziare questa puntata
Io e te Certo Ma perché c'è qualcun
altro Non lo so che dici Oh ragazzi
è una cosa che
Allora Cecilia cantarano Lollo Barolo Io
vi preparo subito qualcosina da bere
perché sono solamente le 11:30 di
mattina e che non sia mai che vi
deperite
basta dai Sentite ragazzi io nel
frattempo vorrei
sporcare
Non è vero
Ed è subito porno Ed è subito porno
signori Non è vero che è successo un
attimo ragazzi
Io vorrei solamente far vedere vorrei
No
non è vero
Raga io non faccio mai questo effetto ha
un essere umano lo faccio agli oggetti
Boh vabbè partiamo una puntata di vita
buttata
[Musica]
Ma è davvero un gin tonic No è carino
questo set mi passi grazie
Abbiamo tre opzioni oggi è tema libero
per cui abbiamo la possibilità di
giocare abbiamo la possibilità di
pescare una wallpare oppure abbiamo
possibilità di ascoltare dei commenti
dal pubblico su quello che il tema di
oggi Il gioco è un gioco tra di noi
molto carino Molto carino
si chiama analy canali fanali anali
perché insomma ricorda un pochino la
sessualità ecco qual è Perché siete
sullo stesso magari sulla stessa
lunghezza d'onda Ok per cui Magari
potreste essere amici fanali perché li
mettereste sotto con la macchina per
quanto mi stanno antipatici tre foto
bisogna scegliere chi mettere cosa
Capito Ok oh Babbo Natale e barbascura
Jason momoah Ma no no no no no fanale
fanale addirittura
Esatto esatto
Babbo Natale oh perfetto certo hanno le
Babbo Natale
lo sapevi pensavamo barba lunga una cosa
del genere
allora allora allora allora Analizzo
subito mi raccomando ragazzi fateci
sapere qua sotto Quali sono le vostre di
classifiche Questo è fondamentale perché
da qui si capisce se una persona può
essere o no amica Raga ve lo dico io
canale Ismaele è quella sotto
cattivissima cioè perché poi crudele al
punto giusto Ti fai certe risate e
compagnia bella Ursula anale con tutti
quei tentacoli letteralmente Malefica
anale Ursula fanale dico anale Ursula
solo perché mi sono travestito da Ursula
da Halloween quindi ho un legame
abbastanza stretto conoscenza puoi far
vedere Certo in passato sono stata un
po' cattiva
dai Guarda che per togliere quel viola
dalla faccia tanto tempo eh no il
coraggio è stato metterlo prima che Tony
metterlo sono andato in un locale dopo e
una è venuta da me fa Ma se travestito
da blackface stai facendo la blackface e
adesso no io sono una sola perché se
andate a vedere le immagini
tipo vecchie di quando facciamo il
blackface tipo per fare Certo ci sono le
labbra rosse la carnagione è sempre vero
e quindi insomma pensava che fossi tu
sei morto morto Qual è Ursula delle tre
No no Fra Fra Francesco non so di che
state a parlare tu cos'è che facevi da
piccolo ascolta la Cristina D'Avena
guardavo Ambra e i cartoni mai te no
questi No questi li ho mai visti la
prima mi dice qualcosa la terza proprio
zero davanti
li conosci l'ultimo Sì gli altri due non
no no no no no no è vero che secondo te
non te lo ricordi il nome Chi è il primo
Pop Voldemort Io non ho mai visto Harry
Potter Vabbè Ah lo so ma questa è una
cosa che è un no no per favore Lollo
Lollo per favore ti chiedo quanta gente
si incazza quando ti costa
il problema è che ne vai fiero non lo
spari così eh proprio cioè
su tutti
Ceci ti prego Lollo vi prego vi prego
leggi i commenti sotto sto video dopo
questa io ti posso proteggere fino a un
certo punto Poi oltre non c'entro che ha
riportato il mio ho detto che non ho mai
visto ma il secondo è Rasputin Vabbè
Rasputin però altre immagini Anastasia
si vabbè però rasputi un'immagine con In
generale come pezzo di merda anche Star
Wars quello neanch'io quello neanch'io
quello neanch'io Star Wars fanale Darth
Vader Vader Darth Vader giusto
Father Darth Vader Ok sono tuo padre
quindi sarà Darth Vader Ok ragazzi
canale Voldemort Secondo me le risate
che ti fai Chi ti può Sì
ucciso e anale Rasputin d'accordo con te
Concordo con te perché ci sono dei
ritrovamenti di alcune zone di Rasputin
interessanti Ah io forse Darth Vader
chissà cosa si nasconde sotto
quell'armatura Ah ah ah in difficoltà
li sai che sono allora quello in mezzo è
Cannavacciuolo il il primo dovrebbe
essere Barbieri sì e l'ultimo è l'ultimo
è coso è zitto ce l'hai ce l'hai ce
l'hai palesa Oh no Terence Hill Come si
chiama
chef Terence Hill
inizia con la c Cracco Bravo Sì c'è un
nome tipo Terence Hill Cracco usa come
si chiama quell'altro faceva chicken
il canale anale fanale inverso fanale
anale per me quindi canale fanale anale
Harry Potter
facciamo Dai chi sono e prima Harry
Potter Ok Il secondo è il padre di Harry
Potter Certo è il terzo nonno
Vabbè chi ti figlio padre o nonno anale
Eh quello è il cattivo in mezzo È un po'
antipatico
granny il padre fanale e canale è Harry
Potter almeno lo conosco come parla
il film magari io fanale Harry Potter ma
non ci penso manco un secondo mamma
Harry Potter
lui che fa cazzate
andiamo avanti Allora ragazzi a questo
punto facciamo una cosa così molto
semplice ci sono delle domande domande
su aneddoti delle vostre vite alle voi
dovete rispondere però sinceramente Ok
chi volete mandare avanti Cecilia
c'ha tanti aneddoti il viaggio più
brutto e un paio d'anni fa sono andata
in campeggio mia madre in Grecia e siamo
andati in macchina cioè traghetto da
otto ore arriviamo in campeggio dopo due
giorni di viaggi e lo aiuto a disfare le
valigie prendo il borsone sulla macchina
e dentro c'era un fucile carico tu dici
perché boh con una fiocina mi fiocino la
gamba quindi levo la suocera
che si apre dovrebbe Ma era solo a una
punta io la levo mi giro verso piede
faccio papà mi sa che mi sono fatta male
Lui leva la mano Ragazzi allora lui mi
prende un po' di Scottex me lo giro
intorno alla voce e fai Vai tranquilla
la macchina mi sveglio e trascinavo la
gamba Allora siamo andati all'ospedale
della Grecia col 8 abitanti arrivo gli
spiego della fiocina ma non parlavano
inglese quindi vi faccio vedere la
fiocina e indico mio padre e pensavo che
lui mi avesse sparato quindi volevano
chiamare la polizia perché purtroppo mio
padre e si è sparato e mi fanno
l'antitetanica e tutte le solite cose
che si fanno esco da lì con le stampelle
e dici di andare a ballare la sera
perché mi ferma niente Ero appena
arrivato in vacanza e prendo una storta
in discoteca su un altro piede quindi
devo entrambe regalare allora carrozzina
ma dico sai che ci aiuta comunque in
spiaggia in spiaggia sulla piccola parte
di piede scoperto che era fasciato mi
punge un'ape e scopriste è allergica
quindi due giorni di viaggio
stupendo Stupendo qualcun altro che si
vuole pescare da parte che ho preso un
treno in ritardo ma in confronto a lei
no niente niente
mangia lo schifo penitenza mangia lo
schifo
piselli
un altro biglietto
in che momento però posso dire non sono
male eh Ma l'hai assaggiato
Guarda che sfiziosi quasi eh
eh
con un Twist Che schifo
ma è tutto così amore
genitori imbarazzanti Allora io da
bambini noi che adesso sia bellissimo
però da ragazzino era proprio brutto
cioè proprio come pigliavano tutti in
giro che mostre che senso ti pigliavano
tutti in giro che ti dicevano brutto
brutto pensa
e siccome c'era un altro bambino che che
chiamavano scorfano per distinguerci
aveva chiamavano Lo Scorfano brutto
Pensa che livello arrivava altro e Body
shaming Allora io ho comprato il diario
quello di scuola a un certo punto
sai che nel diario c'è scritto nome
cognome ehm
assegni particolari
il tempo che era segni particolari
bellissimo di Adriano Celentano parliamo
di tanti anni fa io Comincia a scrivere
sei di particolari B e mi madre mi fai
fermati cosa scrive perché io pensavo si
dicesse così e quindi bellissimo Mia
madre si ferma e ferma e mi fa Ma che
cazzo sta a scrivere io faccio
bellissimo Dice No guardi mi prendono in
giro a scuola ho ritrovato questo diario
da poco dove c'è scritto siccome be era
scritto mia madre era corretto
i particolari Beh nessuno
il
colori e segni particolari Beh adesso
nessuno tu hai fratelli o sorelle uno
che però hanno tenuto dentro una stanza
chiave per 25 anni quindi non sto
scherzando
esatto
che han scritto Beh nessuno Tua madre
può fare qualsiasi cosa tocca a me Lollo
Ti prego Lollo Ti prego io sono io sono
morto dentro da piccolo credevo che
si scrivesse l apostrofo a sdraio Slime
Slime Sì si scrivesse le lenzuola Vabbè
l'inguine normale
si dicesse gastolo invece che ergastolo
perché pensavo che fosse l'arcobaleno
ergastolo perché pensavo che fosse
articolo Romano ergastolo posso dire una
cosa possiamo dare voce a persone che
invece secondo me sono un pochino più
fresche di me perché abbiamo fatto una
domanda alla community e ci sono
arrivati gli audio che Vorrei commentare
insieme a voi legati a quelli che sono
stati momenti più assurdi del 2022 della
gente che ci segue posso chiedervi di
pensare anche al vostro Quando ho
conosciuto il mio attuale ragazzo in una
Trim ah ah
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta Ma il ragazzo è stato
conosciuto Cioè forse stava con uno
Arriva del ragazzo che sarebbe diventato
il suo ragazzo Esatto Oh Erano in tre
che si sono beccati così a caso oppure
lei ha aperto una porta e c'era una
trisome eh piacere ancora iscritto può
essere tutto può essere Mi puoi far
sapere su su Instagram la dinamica di
questo threesome bellissima questa
storia quando ho scoperto che i miei
separati da 14 anni sono amanti e vanno
a letto insieme
Questa è bellissima
Scusa ma 14 anni che queste persone sono
distanti Tu le hai dimenticate le hai
staccate e in realtà di nascosto ritorna
il brivido posso fare una cosa posso
pescarne uno io perché sennò io nel
momento in cui fai come se fosse una
vita buttate la tua io sapevo cecio tu
mi hai detto a me piacerebbe un po' a
condurre un Format tipo questo Cioè
cambio Guglielmo tocca a te Facci ridere
Allora quella volta in cui hai
dimenticato che se lasci il portafoglio
sopra una macchina e poi parti non lo
ritrovi e una volta mi sono dimenticato
che se lasci il computer dall'holld Wild
West e te ne vai poi torni all'Old Wild
West ne trovi sette dei computer ok Come
continua la puntata precedente
Continuiamo con il nostro gioco di
bigliettini
Vale abbiamo altri messaggi dalla
redazione
dalla regia Vai sentiamoli commentiamoli
Lollo voglio sentire un po' il tuo
parere che sei un po' silenzioso un po'
tardi
ho cambiato quattro lavori quest'anno in
tutti e quattro Ho ritrovato il mio ex
coincidenze Io non credo io non so per
dire una cosa molto molto
forte Veramente stiamo dicendo che è una
casualità perché Ci sono volte delle
persone cioè su io ti chiedo scusa se
prendo questo momento per dire una cosa
forte a casa tua ok Ci sono delle
persone che tante volte invece
utilizzano queste occasioni per poter
parlare dei propri ex perché non
riescono a tagliare e andare avanti io
ho avuto amiche che continuavano a
parlare del loro ex di quanto era nostro
di quello che era successo perché era un
modo per rimanerci aggrappate perché si
attente nessuno Tu che fai quando vai al
lavoro perché il tuo ex non lo guardo ma
io gli indifferente Non lo dici
soprattutto il chiedo il nome abbiamo
altre audio dalla regia scordo la mia
macchina aperta davanti alla farmacia
trovo una signora dentro che suona il
clacson
Ok della macchina sua ho detto la
farmacia una mia amica ha lasciato la
macchina aperta e un barbone ha dormito
in quel un clochard Scusate infatti
stavo per dire
Ha dormito ha trovato dimora in questo
veicolo e il giorno dopo ha lasciato un
bigliettino con su scritto Grazie
carino carinissimo parlando di clochard
ho trovato un signore che stava
camminando Poverino e stava tipo
tornando a casa era tutto quanto tipo
zoppicante allora io gli ho detto Ma la
posso portare a casa lui mi guarda e mi
fa Ma sono sporco ah raga io l'ho detto
la prego salga l'ho portato e alla fine
mi ha fatto male devo qualcosa tu hai
detto così
ho 35€
sono €20 No l'ho detto no se ne va di
andiamo a fare serata io bevicchio in
senso che proprio io non sapevo neanche
chi cazzo fossi cioè sono tornato a casa
che sta confusionale entro lascio la
porta aperta Vado in cucina ubriaca
prendo la salsa pomodoro ho pensato se è
quella bevo la spudo perché si alza il
pomodoro tutto questo dietro di me c'era
un ladro perché era entrato un ladro in
questo me guardava che sposava ha fatto
un pomodoro perché è entrato con me esce
si tira fuori la porta e mio padre
Cecilia
[Musica]
Scusate scusate
tanto
perché questo mi avrà visto proprio
entrare io ho lasciato la porta aperta e
mio padre è fatto Oh ha sentito la voce
Questo tu tu tu sbatte la porta ed esce
ma tu sei l'unico che non ha fatto che
non ha interagito con con clochard in
alcun modo
ladri no dove abiti esco poco Ma tu come
fai poi ad andare in giro Scusami tu
adesso non è una cosa grossa che sta per
succedere un nuovo spettacolo sarà uno
spettacolo in inglese sulla storia di
Roma antica che andrà in scena tutti i
giorni per tre mesi in un teatro del
centro Ma stai scherzando Piazza Piazza
di Spagna dice questo Diciamo che figata
Io non non esco più perché
un personaggio clochard nel nella
sceneggiatura
cazzata ho detto Scusate
al giorno deve imparare una cioè un
giorno tranquillo tranquillo Oggi però
non era clochard è un'altra che mi sono
dimenticato la parola È perentorio tu
non sapevi giuro che non sapevo cosa
volesse dire
prontorio come sei
Scusa che vuol dire perentorio l'hai
capito Eh tipo Severo
è un po' anche un intercalare secondo me
è troppo clamodeva perentorio
A me piace tantissimo però secondo me
bisogna l'ecosistema deve tornare ai
suoi inizi Sono curioso ragazzi anche
voi avete in qualcosa così da
sponsorizzare per dare un senso a questa
cecio Certo però non posso fare spoiler
vedrete vedrete in seguito Nel
nell'andare appunto
dell'anno non voglio essere perentoria
se quella cosa succede il 2020
lo facciamo insieme questa cosa noi
siamo molto scaramantici perentoria A
volte anche ci piace comunque mantenere
questo quello di Mistero ecco comunque
lo scopriremo quest'anno
magari lo scoprirete anche voi Dai
Incrociamo le dita Ragazzi io non posso
che ringraziare naturalmente Francesco
De Carlo Cecilia cantaranno il Lollo
Barolo per avermi fatto visita
all'interno degli Studios di casa mia
anzi sono gli Studios degli Studios
Forse perché non sto più a casa tua in
maniera sfocata Facciamo partire un
pochino di mindfulness di sottofondo e
sta addormentando così bacio ciao
Ciao
straordinario dove lui usa tutto di
Harry Potter
Ah è ripeto nel silenzio Sì Lui
giustamente professore di pozioni
mansioni
Ah beh lui è professore di pozioni un
po' stronzo però poi alla fine Eh vabbè
non spoiler non spoiler
se sopporta poi
di che casa Casamonica
bene Casa Monica
[Musica]
Questa è la ragazza Grifondoro
e invece L'ultimo è l'ultimo è coso è
Silente posso dire che lui Silente è
pure un po'
filosofo cioè Beh sì cioè c'era una
frase bellissima che lui dice a un certo
punto che non sono i nostri poteri a
fare le nostre scelte ma le nostre
scelte
[Risate]
i nostri poteri non era così me lo
cancella il tatuaggio
[Risate]
[Musica]